23 years ago today the late Art Modell
fired Bill Belichick is head coach of
the Cleveland Browns and Belichick went
back to being a defensive coordinator
with Bill Parcells and he was the coach
of the Jets for like two hours and then
he becomes the head coach the New
England Patriots in 2000 and the rest is
history I I don't know how well look I
mean the Browns were moving so it's not
like Browns fans are gonna be upset
Ravens fans are the ones who would be
upset about this cuz that's what he
would have been the coach of the
Baltimore Ravens starting in 1996
instead it was Ted marchibroda who took
over the Ravens right out of the gates
and the Ravens have a couple of Super
Bowl championships but they'd only have
six Belichick has six and Belichick
could have been the first coach of the
Baltimore Ravens there probably wouldn't
like that gig right one who grew up on
the grounds of the Naval Academy and all
that fall from Baltimore he probably
would have relished the opportunity to
usher in the new era of football in
Baltimore he got started I believe with
the Colts under marchibroda back in the
mid 70s so that would have made plenty
of reasons would have been plenty of
reasons for Belichick to have that gig
but instead Modell moves in a different
direction and Belichick ends up landing
in New England and everything works out
fairly well although I remember like his
first year in New England was five and
eleven that was 2000 and listening to
the radio on a weekend in 2001 after the
schedule was out we were moving toward
the start of the season and and the the
hosts will remain nameless at least for
now but the host was making the case for
the 2001 Patriots going Owen 16 one week
at a time you know how we engage in that
there's a win there's a loss well this
time around it was just lost lost lost
lost lost
Owen 16 New England Patriots in 2001 and
yes instead they would go on to win the
Super Bowl and that was the first of six
they were five and five at one point
that season but the thing about
Belichick and now Michaels mentioned
this yesterday and and it made its way
into the show today the idea that that
Belichick has amnesia and it's not
selective it's total and complete
amnesia he forgets the winds he forgets
the losses no matter whether things go
well no matter whether things go poorly
what happened yesterday
happened yesterday what happened last
week happened last week we are indeed on
to Cincinnati and that's the way he's
lived as a coach and it makes sense
because there's nothing else you can do
about the things that have already
happened and you're either gonna get too
complacent and content with what you've
achieved or you're gonna let that loss
eat at you to the point where you can't
come back and be as successful as you
need to be and and that's one of the
reasons he's cracked the code it's easy
to say it it's another thing to do it
he's overcoming human nature because
there is a certain amount of human
nature where you're going to get
naturally a little bit relaxed once you
have figured it out or you're gonna get
so consumed with with regret and and
frustration after a big loss that you
can't get past it he always gets past it
he gets his team past it and I think
stats that's one of the reasons why
they've been so great and they happen to
have the greatest quarterback of all
time as they got in the sixth round it
helps yeah boy it really pains you to
say that doesn't it well considering
that he should have been on the 49ers he
wanted to play for the 49ers and so
their Hatcher's apparently we don't
draft good quarterbacks that want to
play for us
Giovanni Carr mozzie and it don't hurt
her half pick and actually remember the
clip from the gap Mariette Mariucci
Stevie said he got ruined in his first
preseason game against the Patriots the
Hall of Fame game in 2000
Giovanni Carm RZ got ruined in that game
and yeah the rest would be history for
both car mazi Levin shot for tombery
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports